so I I have some jokes around starting
nonprofits uh that nonprofits run on two
things passion and
money and uh um and one of the dark
truths of being a nonprofit founder is
that the way to get the money is to talk
about the passion um but then even as
you're talking about the passion you're
thinking okay how do I get the
money right right right yeah and and if
you think about it a lot of times people
the nonprofit sector will say you know
we have to beg for money we have to beg
for money well guess what entrepreneurs
have to beg for money too it's not just
the nonprofit sector where you're
begging for money it's in the nonprofit
sector you we people have miniaturized
Ambitions as Susan barisford at the Ford
Foundation used to say about how much
money they're entitled to like in the
non in the nonprofit sector doesn't
distinguish the concept of capital
nonprofits think of their Capital as
whatever is in their petty cash so if
they had $23,000 in their petty cash
that's the money they can use to create
something new whether that's a new
fundraising Endeavor or a new program
well that's not how entrepreneurs in the
for-profit sector think about it they
think about what scale do I want this
idea to um enter the marketplace at how
much money would it cost to bring it out
at that scale and let me go to the
capital markets and get that much money
so I can do it right their dreams aren't
um Limited did by the amount of money in
the bank account I mean imagine if if
Elon mus I can't remember whether he
bought SpaceX or Tesla first but let's
say he bought Tesla first and he wants
to start SpaceX well he doesn't look at
the the the the petty cash in Tesla to
go start SpaceX right he goes to the
capital markets to do that and so this
um oversight of the concept and power of
capital in the nonprofit sector is is a
big problem and it's driven by the fact
that the that the sector has been so
oppressed um that that so many of the
freedoms we give to business have been
taken away from the nonprofit sector in
the name of some kind of an ethic you
want to know why nonprofits haven't
changed the world the way we hoped that
they would because that is not what we
asked them to do we ask them
emphatically and consistently and we
still do keep your overhead and your
salaries low so that's what they did and
if you keep your overhead and your
salaries low we will reward you with
donations regardless of the fact that
you may not be having any impact in the
world and impact becomes an entirely
secondary thing we don't
consider the nonprofit sector to be to
have the potential to be a lead player
in changing the world we don't think
that the nonprofit sector can could do
that we think of it as a gesture we
think of it as something nice that uh
you know people dabble in when they're
when they're retired or when they're um
done what they're day and and and and
it's why um I challenge anyone to go
back and and listen to all of the
presidential debates of the last five
decades and and see if you hear the
nonprofit sector mentioned once as a
critical element of how we solve
problems for the least Among Us um and
and as it's currently constrained it's
not it's not capable of taking on that
role but if we released it from these
anachronistic anachronistic constraints
and what do I mean by that I mean well
we don't allow nonprofits to use money
to attract the absolute best people to
solve problems we don't allow nonprofits
to advertise so that they can excite the
general public about the work that
they're doing and grow we don't allow
them to take risks when it comes to new
fundraising and new ways to grow we we
measure them in 12-month increments so
we don't give them any time and we don't
give them a capital market and the
for-profit sector gets all of those
things well if you gave all of those
things to the nonprofit
sector it could address the issues with
the help of business and government but
could take the lead in addressing the
issues of poverty that still remain at
14% in the United States illiteracy
that's been at 14% for the last four
decades breast cancer where the
mortality has been around hovering
around 40,000 for the last four decades
with no change suicide where the
mortality now approaches 40,000 up from
10 years ago all of these problems are
problems where the nonprofit sector is
uniquely doing on the ground R&D that
nobody else is doing to figure out what
Innovations might work at solving those
problems um but they don't have the
scale the the problems are massive in
scale massive in scale these are
multibillion decim million decillion
decillion problems and we want our
Charities to be small and when they
start to get too too big we think oh I'm
going to give to this other charity
because they they're big enough well not
if they haven't solved the problem
they're not big enough right well the
the ideal nonprofit puts itself out of
business which as you're saying never
happens because our nonprofits aren't
actually uh designed to hit a scale
where they can solve the problem yeah
and one I'm sorry to interrupt but one
of the things that kills me is this
notion that people say well we need to
make our nonprofit sustainable nobody
wants your nonprofit to be sust
stainable they they they want you to go
out of business I had a client call me 5
years ago say we're we're celebrating
our 50th Anniversary as a breast cancer
organization 25th anniversary as a
breast cancer organization we want to
tell people everything we're going to do
in the next 25 years I mean do do you do
you realize how ironic that people don't
want breast cancer to be around in
another 25 years they don't want to be
celebrating anniversaries they want
these problems to be
ended hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you